So first we can write down the partial
orders that we see in the distributed system.
You can see that 'a' happens before 'b',
'b' happens before 'c', 'c' happens before 'e' and
these are purely coming from the chain of
communication and local events that are happening over here.
When we come over here, we also observe
that 'f' happens before 'e' that's because of sequentiality
Of this process. And similarly, we can see that
in process P1, a happens before d. So these
are the partial orders and we already have an
ordering for the events that follow this chain because the
logical time stamp are assigned in this fashion. And
in order to derive a total order we said
we basically will believe the event time stamps. To
order them totally. So we can order these events totally.
A1, B2, C3, E5. We can order them totally.
Now let's look at the concurrent events that are
happening. The concurrent events that are happening is d
over here is concurrent with all the other events
in the other processes. D is concurrent with b
and c. It is concurrent with f and e.
And similarly if you look at this event f,
it's concurrent with all the events that are happening
in process P2 and P1, right. So this is
what you as the concurrent events. So now what we
have to do is, given that these concurrent events, we
have to somehow Fit them into a total order. As
I said before no problem in fitting these guys
into a total order because they already have time stamps
that distinguish them from one another. The time stamp associated
with a is 1, b is 2, c is 3,
e is 5. No problem with that. So the real problem comes with f and d. Now the
sequentiality of this process is what made the time stamp associated with e to
be 5 because the message that came over here had a time stamp of 3 but we
associated a time stamp of 5 with e. Because the local event preceding e have
a time stamp of 4, so we pick 5 as the time stamp to associate with e, so that
the sequentiality of this process p3 is respected. So, we've
got this, and now we've got f and d, and
so f obviously is going to sneak in Before e, that,
that's no problem, that is coming from the sequentiality, but
where will we put d, do we should be put d after e? Or should we put d before e?
In the total order. This is where the
breaking the tie using process id comes into
play, Because these two guys are concurrent events
in the system, we are breaking the tie using
the process ID. P1 happens to be less
than P3 in process ID space and therefore we
are going to say in the total order,
dis going to be ahead, totally ordered, before e.
So the final ordering that we end up with, the total order that we end up with,
is a0, b, c, F, and then d. And then
e, so that's the total order that we come up with. Respecting the logical
time stamp associated with the events, and
breaking the tie using the process ID.